we're like the world is going to end in
12 years if we don't address climate
change to avert the worst
consequences of climate crisis we have
nine years left
we're going to pass the point of no
return within the next eight to ten
years
you've probably heard the claim that we
have a dozen years or less to stop
climate change from inflicting permanent
damage on the planet
we've already waited too long to deal
with this climate crisis
we can't wait any longer president biden
cited the deadline when announcing that
the u.s would rejoin the paris climate
accord an international agreement to
curb
greenhouse gases i'm signing today an
executive order to supercharge our
administration's ambitious plan
to confront the existential threat of
climate change it is an existential
threat
and we're told by all the leading
scientists in the world we don't have
much time i read the report that the
people claiming a 2030 deadline are
relying upon
and they have misread it aaron brown is
a mathematician and statistician who was
taught at nyu and ucsd
he's also the former chief risk officer
at the hedge fund aqr capital management
brown says that activists and
politicians are misrepresenting the
science in a rush to implement unwise
solutions
i am here to say our house is on fire we
must change
almost everything in our current
societies rather than protecting the
most at-risk ecosystems and populations
these proposals are likely to backfire
and cause further harm both to the
environment and to the most vulnerable
people on the planet whether you think
climate change is an existential issue
or merely one of several important
threats we face in the future
is a completely separate issue from how
quickly we should act
people pushing a 20 30 deadline are
committing us to very risky solutions
that could backfire
based on all the evidence i think we
have more time we can consider
reasonable solutions that don't risk the
economy and don't risk the planet
and the people will actually stick to
for the long term i don't
want you to be hopeful i want you to
panic
so where did the claim that we have
until 2030 come from
among the first to popularize it was
teenage climate activist greta tunberg
who when speaking before the u.n
chastised world leaders for their
inaction
people are suffering people are dying
and all you can talk about is money and
fairy tales of eternal economic growth
how dare you
toonberg took the 2030 deadline from a
2018 special report by the un's
intergovernmental panel on climate
change or ipcc
authored by the world's top climate
scientists and widely considered the
gold standard in the field
this is a report that was actually asked
for by governments under the paris
agreement
they're going to get together in poland
later in the year to talk about the next
steps
and our report is the only named input
into their negotiations
many politicians activists and
journalists like tunberg have cited
their report as the basis for their
claim
starting in 2018 that there were just 12
years to save the planet or that 2030
was a cliff
reports that came out from the leading
scientists in this world who told us
that we have
12 years the scientists are absolutely
unanimous on this
that we have no more than 12 years
scientists tell us have said a thousand
times
all of us could be at a point of no
return but after the ipcc report was
released
prominent climate scientists including
some of the report's authors
publicly raised doubts about the 2030
deadline the panel did not say that we
have 12 years left to save the world
ipcc working group co-chair james skia
told the associated press
the hotter it gets the worse it gets but
there is no cliff edge
please stop saying something globally
bad is going to happen in 2030 wrote
fellow leading report author miles allen
the ipcc does not draw a planetary
boundary at 1.5 degrees celsius
beyond which like climate dragons all
the time limited frames are [ __ ]
nasa's gavin schmidt told axios we are
less than 12 years away
from not being able to undo our mistakes
these numbers aren't anyone's opinions
or political views this is the current
best available science
did climate activists misread the report
or was it a purposeful attempt to
mislead the public
that's not clear but the ipcc report
does use vague language that made it
susceptible to misinterpretation the
forward for example states that without
a quote
sharp decline in greenhouse gas
emissions by 2030 there will be
irreversible loss of the most fragile
ecosystems and crisis after crisis for
the most vulnerable people and societies
the fall off a cliff idea is not
supported by the ipcc report
it's true that risks increase as
temperatures ratchet up
but there's no sudden tipping point
where climate change becomes
irreversible
properly read the report is actually an
argument for predictable sustainable
solutions over several decades using
experimentation innovation
not a rush toward risky short-term
solutions
that focus entirely on warming to the
detriment of general environmental
stewardship
so what does the ipcc report say about
the year 2030
the most specific claim it makes is that
quote global warming is likely to reach
1.5 degrees celsius between 2030 and
2052
if it continues to increase at the
current rate there isn't a scientific
consensus that reaching 1.5 degrees
above pre-industrial levels will mean
global catastrophe
but let's assume that the activists are
correct that staying under that level
should be the goal of public policy when
will we hit 1.5 degrees of warming under
the author's assumptions
by calculating the current rate of
global warming and plotting it out along
a graph
we see that the answer to the question
they pose is the year 2052
but remember that they gave a year range
starting in 2030 and ending in 2052
how did they get there the 2030 date
that activists have trumpeted appears in
this chart in the report
in the worst case scenario or the top of
the shaded area
we see that warming hits 1.5 degrees by
the year 2030.
in the best case scenario or the bottom
of the shaded area we see that warming
actually never hits 1.5 degrees
but what most commentators haven't paid
attention to is that this is not a
measure of actual warming
this chart is actually showing estimates
of anthropogenic warming or warming that
the authors hypothesize is caused by
humans
the gray line shows the actual changes
in the planet's surface temperatures
and the orange shaded area represents
the author's estimates of what humans
are contributing to the overall warming
trend
so the worst case scenario that gets us
to 1.5 degrees by 2030
does not represent actual temperature
increases but the upper limit of how
much the authors think humans could
possibly be contributing if our
activities were happening in isolation
so what explains the difference between
actual global warming and the global
warming caused by humans
the authors believe that if
anthropogenic warming is up here
there must be a naturally occurring
cooling force that has brought
temperatures down
if human caused warming is down here
that means there's been a naturally
occurring warming effect that has
brought temperatures up
they aren't sure which is happening
which is why they're not sure whether
global warming caused by humans is up
here
or down there the point is that the 2030
date as it appeared in the ipcc report
was the worst case scenario not in terms
of actual global warming but in terms of
warming caused only by humans
independent of what's actually happening
in the environment people making the sky
as following claims probably haven't
read the report and think that it's
saying
actual temperatures will increase by 1.5
degrees in 2030.
the range of dates the report discusses
are actually about human contribution
to global warming if you think the
problem of global warming is higher
temperatures melting ice caps rising sea
levels
then you care about the date the report
projects actual temperatures
will reach 1.5 degrees which is 2052 if
things continue at the current rate
is it possible that actual warming could
result in baseline temperatures above
1.5 degrees by 2030 the rate of global
warming would have to speed up to about
three times what we have observed in
past decades
which no serious climate scientists
including the authors of the ipcc report
claim is likely to happen
so why did the ipcc report focus on a
date which is the worst case scenario
not in terms of actual global warming
but of human contributions to warming as
if they were happening in a vacuum
after the report's release co-chair of
the working group deborah roberts
justified their presentation of the data
and conclusions as an effort to project
a line in the sand and what it says to
our species that this is the moment and
we must act now
and i hope it mobilizes people and dense
the mood of complacency
but brown says that distorting the
science is the opposite of what the ipcc
authors and other climate scientists
should be doing
it's a very dangerous game if you want
strong sensible long-term solutions to
climate change
to scare people into them by making wild
short-term predictions
that can backfire in one of two ways you
may scare people into doing
short-term irrational solutions that do
more harm than good
or 20-30 might roll around and it's not
as much warmer as you said it was going
to be
and you could take a lot of steam out of
the movement to do anything at all
if we were to accept 2030 as a
meaningful deadline the only path
forward is politically unfeasible
economically devastating and immensely
risky according to the ipcc
limiting global warming to 1.5 degrees
would require rapid and far-reaching
transitions in land
energy industry buildings transport and
cities
all taking place in under a decade
emissions reductions as currently
envisioned won't work
supporters of the paris climate accord
acknowledged that if fully implemented
it still won't come close to keeping
warming under its goal of 1.5 degrees
even if we did everything that we said
we were going to do
when we signed up in paris we would see
a
rise in the earth's temperature which is
catastrophic just reducing emissions
is not enough our greenhouse gas
emissions
has to stop zero in 2050
means nothing if high emission continues
even for a few years they're not
thinking through the implications of
what they're calling for
if we need a solution by 2030 that means
geoengineering and other dramatic
untested strategies
with unpredictable effects invest in
millions of jobs and wind
solar and carbon capture the supposed
2030 deadline has become a justification
for diverting massive resources into
largely unproven direct carbon capture
and geoengineering projects
and at the same time for shutting down
much of the global economy
people who really believe 2030 is a
disaster year
have to focus on geoengineering
scattering beads to reflect sunlight
injecting aerosols in the stratosphere
rushing these things through without
proper testing has entirely
unpredictable
consequences and could backfire to much
worse environmental damage
than the problem they're intended to
solve the only other thing that works on
this horizon
is bans we ban coal we ban air travel we
shut down many electrical power plants
and mainly we have to do it in china and
india
this has unpredictable economic effects
except we know it will cause a
considerable decline in gross domestic
product
that means we reverse the rise out of
poverty for much of the world
and we create economic problems larger
than we got in the great financial
crisis of 2008
and they're permanent but what if as the
report's underlying data suggest
we actually have more time to limit
global warming to below catastrophic
levels
if we have 30 years to address climate
change then we have much more palatable
options
first of all the economy and technology
are naturally moving away from fossil
fuels
then we can give entrepreneurship and
bottom-up innovation a time to work
we can adopt policies that gently nudge
the economy in the right direction
without creating the disruption and
misery of sudden bans
if we have more time we can get away
from the pure focus on temperature
we can consider balanced solutions that
consider all environmental issues
and all economic issues we can try to
reduce the total human environmental
impact
sensible solutions can build a better
world for our grandchildren
scientists tell us that this is the
decisive decade
we no longer have time to leave out the
science
activists politicians and journalists
who trumpet 2030 as a meaningful
deadline
may be doing so in a desperate attempt
to get the public to take the threat of
global warming seriously
this is our world war ii i feel
a need for all of us to breathe fire
after new york congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez invoked the 12-year
deadline
she responded to critics by tweeting
you'd have to have the social
intelligence of
a sea sponge to think it's literal but
the best way to address climate change
is not to mislead people and stoke panic
but to rationally assess the science and
chart the best course for both the
planet
and the people living on it there's a
partisan divide on this issue
between people who think it's a very
serious problem with a short fuse
and people who think it's not much of a
problem with a long fuse
i think most sensible people should
regard it as a serious problem with a
long fuse there isn't much place for
this
in the media and on campaign trails the
key factor is for the last 50 years we
have been reducing the amount of energy
it
takes to create a dollar of wealth if
that trend continues and can be
accelerated
it means we can have a booming economy
we can have prosperity for
all we can bring people out of poverty
all over the world
without using a lot of energy and
therefore without a big environmental
footprint
we don't have to choose between
prosperity and a good environment we can
have both
you